Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm checking in on you.
You specifically,
not anybody else.
I'm checking in on you.
The kind of person that actually listens.
How about that?
Huh?
Remember those people,
whenever something fucking really bad happens,
you can't,
you literally cannot fucking,
you just cannot go on the Internet and go on to social media.
You just can't.
You can't,
you just can't fucking do it.
You know?
And even was some bad just from people just deliberately misinterpret something.
I saw this is fucking jerk off,
was going like congratulations to the eagles who didn't fucking Neil against the
national anthem.
You know,
that was never
the guy was doing it.
A peaceful protest about police brutality.
Whether he agreed with that or whether you didn't go to
um,
yeah,
when to kneeling become disrespect.
I hate my neighbor.
Anytime he walks out of his house,
I'm going to kneel.
That'll show him
a boy,
uh,
another fucking jerk off dead.
What fucking jerk offs too.
And the fucking media is now going to make that person famous and talk about the
numbers like it's ESPN when you're talking about dead kids,
it's just fucking unbelievable.
It's unbelievable.
And then there's no way,
there was no way to have any sort of conversation about how to fulfill God's
sakes,
how to try and make this not happen.
This is clearly
something that just didn't happen when I was growing up.
And now ever since that fucking Colorado Shit,
it's like a fad.
Like what the fuck is going on?
And you can literally cannot,
you just can't talk to anybody about it.
You can't,
it's,
everybody gets all fucking,
they're going to take your guns away.
And other people,
we got to get rid of all the guns.
Guns don't kill people.
People kill people.
You know?
I Dunno.
I have no idea what the solution is.
I know people on the left literally look at guns is if they're alive and they're
sinister things,
which is ridiculous.
And then people on the other side literally get to the point that they want to
buy a bazooka to fucking defend their house.
It's fucking unbelievable.
There's gotta to be some something in the middle that everybody can agree upon
first and foremost.
Yet,
I really truly believe you have got to stop showing these people,
the people that do it and making them famous.
You got to stop fucking doing that.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm fucking wrong.
I have no fucking idea.
And I might be wrong.
I think maybe on a regular basis,
people break into people's houses in groups of 40 and you need to have
an assault rifle.
I don't know.
I don't live in the middle of nowhere.
I do understand this though,
that if you live in the middle of fucking nowhere,
that calling the cops is not an option.
Yeah.
Me,
some of these fucking people that live in farm houses,
that goddamn driveway is like eight miles long.
Okay.
So by the time the cops get there and make a right turn to drive all the way up
there fucking driveway,
you know as Jason Vorhees Oh,
I was fucking name is chase and his poor farmer round his house.
What the fuck is he supposed to do?
You know?
But I dunno.
Yeah.
Isn't a shotgun good?
I know that would stop me.
I don't know what kind of people are out there,
but you know,
some of these kids,
they get themselves on the math and in have been still like fucking x men.
So maybe you need an ar 15.
I don't know shit about guns.
I have no idea.
But I just,
it's just so bizarre that no one wants what's happening to be happening.
And everybody just starts insulting each other,
you know,
using that stupid fucking,
liberal snowflake and,
and,
and fucking right wing gun nut.
They just start name calling like any,
I love when people do that.
Like that's gonna make somebody on the other side listen to you.
MMM.
I have no idea.
But the first thing that I would do is I would,
I would stop the media coverage
of it
and,
uh,
I dunno.
Cause for whatever reason,
I'm starting to really think that that is feeding this.
I mean,
it's fucking,
it's fucking insane.
It's fucking insane.
And uh,
I dunno,
I just don't think he should know the name of the person.
And when you convict a person,
I think they should immediately be put to death.
And then that's it.
And that's it over.
Okay.
And the fucking story,
I don't,
I don't know if got a fucking,
we're all,
you know,
all I know is like,
yeah,
I got a gig tonight and I was going to go on
social media to promote it and to go on there and it's just fucking la.
Everybody just fucking yelling at each other like they do every time.
Um,
I dunno.
What are you going to do?
All right.
They had to get that out there.
I don't know what I just got out there.
I don't know what I just fucking put out there.
All I know is I had a great Valentine's Day.
Oh,
did I have a great Valentine's Day?
I actually went out with my lovely wife,
which we never fucking do.
I had the best date.
We,
uh,
oh my God,
you guys,
I had like the best day I got a facial.
No,
I went to,
um,
I w we,
I took my wife and my lovely daughter,
we went down to a,
we went out to this pizza place out in Pasadena and we went in and it was like a
total like townie vibe,
which I really miss that shit since I've left Massachusetts all those years ago
and moved to New York City.
There was never a townie vibe in New York City.
It's a fucking city now.
I live in La.
It's a fucking city.
But this place had like a,
like I went in there and he just could feel it was like locals and Real Los
Angelenos if that's the word,
like grew up like I love meeting people that are from Los Angeles because they
don't shit on it the way everybody else who lives out here and be good.
You could get to it.
We can blue.
It's like,
yeah,
this traffic because you and I moved out here.
We're part of the problem.
Um,
so we went out there,
the pizza was really good and uh,
you know,
got a root beer and all that stuff.
Acting like I was in fucking seventh grade again.
And then,
um,
I decided that I was going to take my wife out on Valentine's Day with
absolutely no plant.
We didn't make any reservations,
none of that bullshit.
She goes,
what do you want to go?
I was like,
I don't know,
maybe go find a dive bar.
We'd be,
I dunno,
probably end up at a taco truck tonight.
Let's just go drive around.
So we got all dressed up.
I took her up on Mulholland,
the amazing views,
Mulholland drive where a lot of people think that's where James Dean died.
Um,
at least I did for a while.
he did and he died.
I don't know.
I can't remember.
It's like up near up for like fucking Bakersfield Isam Shit.
But anyways,
we,
uh,
we did that drive and then,
um,
Nia goes,
you know what I would love right now.
She goes,
I know I'm not going to get it,
you know,
cause it's Valentine state and everything's fucking nuts.
Uh,
I would love like
these fucking tuna tar tar tacos.
And then they got this dessert where they got a fucking chocolate chip cookie in
a skillet that they heat up and they put ice cream on top of it.
So you know,
she says that Shit,
I know I'm never going to get it.
So you know me,
I'm right on the hook.
She pulls me in the boat.
I'm like,
well where,
where did they do that?
So says the name of the restaurant.
She goes,
but it's Valentine's Day.
There's no way we're going to get in.
And I was like,
well,
it's just,
that's what everybody's thinking.
Let's just call up,
see if we can just go up to the bar.
So we call the place up and they say,
well no,
unfortunately we're all sold out.
But like outside,
if you want to sit outside those tables by the pool,
so like,
yeah,
fuck it,
we'll do that.
So we show up after just fucking having this nice zen night.
All of a sudden now we drive it to the madness of fucking Valentine's Day.
We pull up this as long line at the valet were the very next car.
And I see this guy walking out with the sign,
I'm like,
oh,
this motherfucker's gonna Save Valley's called bomb sets it down salary.
It's fucking full.
But normally I'd be,
I would have had like a fucking Tourette's moment,
but I just,
I just,
for some reason didn't give a shit.
I rolled down the window.
I said,
all right,
where can I park?
He goes,
you know,
just try to get some street parking,
just read the signs,
Blah Blah Blah.
So,
you know,
my wife's wearing heels and uh oh,
we're wearing our matching me undies underwear too.
So
I let her lead and she walks away and these new technologies,
cars,
I'm driving away and I'm thinking,
wait,
she has the keys.
Like how is this car still driving?
And I didn't want to stop.
So I drive,
I go around the corner,
I'm like,
it's this thing literally going to conk out in the middle of the street and I
find street parking and there's a sign that says no parking any fucking time
unless you have a sticker and all of that.
And I was just like,
ah,
I'll gives a fuck.
I'll get a ticket,
right?
So I get out of the car now I realize I can't lock it.
Then I got mail in there and shit.
So now I got to go back down,
get the fucking keys.
So I'm walking down the hill and I swear to God,
all of a sudden this kid comes out of this alley
and just the way he's walking,
it's just weird.
But he's in front of me,
which I'm fine with.
And then he just stops and he lets me go by and I'm like,
ah,
Shit.
Okay.
But he's small,
right?
But who knows?
Maybe he has an ar 15.
Yeah,
I don't fucking know.
You know he lives in an alley,
right?
What if 48 homeless people all come at him at once?
The man has to defend himself,
a platoon of homeless people.
So he,
uh,
looks at me,
this is going to sound self serving,
but he dead.
He goes,
ah.
I know you,
I've seen you Bababa Blah,
blah.
And I'm like,
Hey,
what's going on?
And he goes,
yeah,
I know you're a famous guy.
I am.
I make done.
Not really.
He goes,
oh,
you're one of those guys.
You know why you all want to be known about blah?
I'm like,
Dad,
it's not dad.
Just fucking,
you know,
I just want to be like,
no,
dude.
You know what?
I'm just walking down the street and you came out of an alley and you're talking
to me and this is fucking weird.
It's socially weird.
You know,
it's weird.
it's fucking weird.
Stop acting like it's not fucking weird.
And now you're behind me.
You fucking asshole.
So then I slow down.
Now at least he's beside me.
I forget that was a good martial arts move.
You know?
Even though I don't know martial arts,
right?
I felt like the Gracie family was a little more little less disappointed in me.
MMM.
So then he starts talking to me about how he was living in Rome for the last
three months,
and for the first time in his life,
putting living I had of working,
and
he's talking about this shit,
and I'm participating in this conversation.
I don't want to be.
And,
and I'm trying to give the quickest fucking answers possible.
You know,
I mean,
I should have just said like,
dude,
I don't want to be in this conversation,
but you know how this fucking world is now.
I don't know.
I don't want to piss him off.
I don't know what he has on him.
Okay.
So anyways,
he starts giving me his philosophy.
He used the word society like three fucking times.
Um,
okay.
Finally I get to the front of the restaurant and I do my wrap it up.
Move.
Well,
hey man,
it was nice meeting you,
which is a complete fucking lie.
Yeah.
Amen.
Thank you for that creepy last 40 yards of this walk where I was waiting to fill
a knife,
going to my kidneys.
MMM.
You enjoy your evening,
right?
I couldn't say that.
I was like,
Hey,
it was nice talking to you.
If you believe in a higher powered,
is that breaking a commandment of lying?
Thou shall not lie.
Do you know
Jesus falls followed all the comp commandments?
Right.
Look what happened to him.
Maybe that's why I've been able to lip since I'm 49.
Maybe Jesus should it,
if he lied a little more,
are you the son of God?
No,
I don't know.
I know what you're talking about.
He could have continued his life in construction.
Yeah.
It's realized.
I had my fucking Invisalign it
out
by the way,
dude.
My fucking teeth look amazing.
I only got four [inaudible].
They are so straight.
It's so fucking white.
I swear to God.
I looked like an old bald Farrah Fawcett.
That's how good I look right now.
Let's just say Charlie might have a new angel next season.
Um,
and I'll wear the fairer wig.
I don't give a fuck,
you know,
nice four camera shoot,
get in and out in about three hours.
That's what I'm looking for.
What's the Gig I'm looking for?
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
So then I get in the restaurant and uh,
it was fun.
Hilarious.
I get the keys and then I got to walk back up.
Just give me the keys.
I get back up there,
right?
I locked the fucking car.
I'd come back down and it was perfect because we weren't in the main restaurant.
We were out by the pool where they had like heating lamps and it was cold and
shit.
It was where all the single people,
where there's plenty of fucking seats in inside the restaurant was was,
that's where all the drama was.
All the chicks looking at what the other chicks of fucking,
wherein all the guys feeling pressure that they got to give a ring that night.
The fucking marriages that are on the rocks,
but they can dig it up for one more fucking year.
They're going to do this phony dance and go out.
All of that shit was in there.
We fucking walked outside.
My wife's up at the bar talking to some woman who was there by herself and
immediately I'm thinking like,
this is fucking unbelievable.
Not only
did we get a seat at the restaurant we wanted to go to on Valentine's Day,
I actually have a very small chance at getting a threesome right now.
This is fucking incredible.
So,
so fucking with you guys.
But I'm not gonna lie to you if I didn't.
If I did not,
if I didn't have that fucking thought,
I'm a man,
baby.
Um,
so we're up there,
right.
And,
uh,
we ended up,
you know,
just going over,
we've got a table and literally the exact fucking thing that my beautiful wife
who looked absolutely stunning.
Fucking stunning.
Um,
yeah,
exact thing that she wanted to order.
She was able to order that and I got my phone to poor chap and we just sat there
laughing.
Okay.
And how perfect.
The evening was in for the first week.
We made no plans whatsoever.
And,
um,
okay.
And then that was it.
And then we came home.
So I,
all these years,
I,
you know,
it's funny,
the bartender listens to the podcast.
Okay.
And he goes,
Holy Shit.
He goes,
I thought you didn't go out on Valentine's Day.
Right.
I'm like literally caught it at an accidental lie here.
And so I would just,
I told him,
you know,
I told him the truth because he didn't walk out of an alley and then slow down
so you could walk behind me.
Um,
that was just like,
yeah,
usually don't,
but it's just sort of fucking came together.
So there you go.
People,
there's a different way.
Go out and don't have any plan.
And you know what year the women kind of liked that,
that there's something that they,
you know,
we say say that knows fucking magazines.
I let it go spontaneous,
you know,
take him somewhere where is a view?
Right.
Tell them they look good.
Give him a couple of kisses and that type of shit be all affectionate.
Yeah.
Now I'm telling you if you just fucking do that and end up at a taco truck,
they,
you know,
at least,
okay.
They say that that will keep them out.
I,
you know,
something reality is you can't do that every year.
You know what I mean?
Cause you know,
no,
it's just the guys.
If worked one year we're going to do it the next 20 fucking years in a row and
they're going to be bored by the next year.
You just didn't put any thought in this at all.
Did you,
we finally talking about,
came up with this last year.
That was last year.
Come up with something else.
You know,
what the fuck did you come up with?
Other than getting yourself all dolled up,
wait,
wait.
Where is your creative input?
Um,
so anyways,
by the way,
speaking of just gimme the keys,
uh,
I didn't forget if I mentioned this on Monday.
I went to Todd Rex's tapings and he absolutely fucking murdered.
I'm so proud of them.
Went out there.
It wasn't nervous at all,
just fucking destroyed.
Um,
and it was so fun to watch him making fun of his family and watching his kids
die in laughing like a,
I know kids love their dad,
but I'm telling you,
Todd rex is kids fucking love him.
I,
you know,
it's funny,
I knew how much his kids loved them before I even met his kids.
I was just,
he's such as silly,
fun fucking dude.
I was like,
dude,
your key was talking about his kids.
I was like,
dude,
you're fucking kids.
Love you.
And he just smiled.
He's like,
yeah,
they do.
And I was like,
I bet your wife gets fucking annoyed.
You know?
She's like a big fucking kid.
I feel like I'm going to have that relationship with my wife soon because
I came to tell you how fucking,
what a great it.
My kids like walking now and she actually likes to rough house,
which is awesome.
And um,
basically right before she goes to bed,
you know,
I have her like energy or she's,
I have her so fucking amped up because we played this game in the,
uh,
in the living room where she starts to crawl away and I act like I'm upset and
that's how the game started.
And then she like starts to crawl away as fast as she can.
Is She screaming and anticipation that I'm going to come up and grab her and
drag her back to the start and she loves playing it.
That is now evolved into basically I'm crawling behind her like you ever see,
like when the Cheetahs go after like the gazelles or something,
in the end they swipe their back legs so they wipe out.
I mean,
I'm not doing that to her,
but I'm sure they're like grabbing at her foot.
Just got,
ah,
ah.
She's like,
yeah,
like fucking freaking out.
I get her all the way amped up in every night.
We'd die and laugh and Nia sitting there going like,
Bill,
this is the time where we try to lower the stimulation.
We shut off the TV and I'm all out of breath.
Like what?
We're having a good time.
She loves it.
So,
um,
I feel like I'm going to have that,
but that same type of relationship.
But um,
anyways,
plowing ahead.
I had a,
uh,
added Great Valentine's Day.
I hope you did too.
Um,
so
the big news,
the Patrice O'Neal benefit is this Tuesday the sixth annual Patrice O'Neal
benefit.
Um,
one of my favorite gigs.
So this year of the year I should say.
And uh,
you know,
I get to run into all comics that I always see.
Um,
I don't know.
It's like a high school reunion and all that type of shit.
So looking forward to that once again,
it's going to sell out as it has the previous five years.
So I want to thank everybody who went on the air that bought tickets.
Uh,
Blahblahblahblahblah and are you guys watching the Olympics at all?
I haven't been watching as much as I,
you know,
I was at a bar and I was watching curling,
which of course I love,
it's so fucking peaceful watching that shit.
MMM.
I don't know what it is and I still don't understand the fucking game,
but I really enjoy watching it.
And uh,
so when we were out at the bar on Valentine's Day,
not having to wait for a table and getting our food pretty damn quickly,
um,
we were watching the downhill skiing.
If you ever heard the audio of that,
those fucking lunatics,
the men and women that have the fucking nerve to go up to the top of a mountain,
he just point this skis down.
Do you know,
like they are dealing with such like chief forces.
They're literally yelling.
Like anytime they go into a turn a,
they're like going like,
oh,
I have to see that live and I want to be like halfway down the slope just to
watch somebody go by me.
At 80,
90 miles an hour going down of fucking mountain with God Damn Swag Skis on,
just screaming.
Just,
I mean,
you know,
it's like people routinely die in that fucking sport,
the level of balls that that takes.
And then I was watching the cross country skiing,
right?
And just like how fast they're going and the level of cardio.
It was the women doing it and I was just thinking,
there's no way to please that woman in bed.
Like the level of her cardio,
she's going to be going harder,
harder.
You like fuck.
You know,
she just sitting there not even breaking a sweat.
It's like the,
she can cross country ski from it for fucker where I live out to South Dakota
without even breaking a sweat.
What the fuck am I going to do to you in the bedroom is going to even remotely
make you even realize it's happening.
These are the things that I think of when I watched the Olympics.
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
just plow ahead.
Um,
these lunatic liberals,
these right wing gun nuts,
eh,
you're all,
y'all.
Every one of you fucking annoys the shit out of me.
What kind of an adult you can,
can you just,
just present your opinion.
So we should make some afterschool special movie where like people who are into
guns and people who are afraid of guns as if they're alive.
Um,
I remember I wanted to get a gun,
you know,
for,
for a home security.
I didn't want to get a fucking machine gun,
you know,
okay.
Coming home with like fucking dead and traders and then they all the hell that
plaster work I have to do.
I kind of [inaudible] she couldn't just fucking get out of pistol,
you know,
squeeze one off.
But there's all these fucking theories too,
by the way.
There's all these goddamn theories on which is the best one for home security.
It,
you know what?
I really believe that it probably depends on where you live in the world.
What is the best one?
Um,
you know,
cause what are you going to do at this point?
Are you going to band guns?
They're already out there.
And I always loved that there's a ban on guns and it's just like,
oh like all the criminals are going to be like,
ah,
well I guess we can't get up and then only they have them.
MMM.
Is there any way to like booby trap your house?
Why don't we get just get like human size glue traps.
You know like you'd do from mice.
You just put them all the way around your house next to every door and every
window.
Right?
It looks like it's grass.
And then when some rapists to some piece of shit goes in and then just the next
morning they're just sitting there looking at you with this stupid ski mass on
stuck in the glue.
Why can't they just do something like that?
MMM.
I Dunno bill.
Cause it would be prohibitively expensive.
Are you going to get all that glue?
How many horses have to die?
All right.
He looks everybody helix.
There are a ton of online mattress retailers popping up these days.
All with a one size fits all solution to a better sleep.
Guess what?
One size doesn't fits all doesn't work.
Of course it doesn't.
One size doesn't fit all.
It never has.
Um,
it's a half shirt for one person.
The other person,
it's it that they're walking around in a nightclub.
He likes sleep.
Offers something that doesn't exist anywhere else.
A mattress personalized to your unique preferences and sleeping style that won't
set you back.
Thousands of dollars.
Go to hell.
Ix,
sleep.com/bird.
Take those simple two to three minutes.
Sleep quiz.
That's of creepy.
Do you lay on your back?
Do you lay on your stomach?
They'll build a custom mattress.
That will be the best thing you've ever slept on for couples.
They even personalize each side of the mattress.
Oh,
look who's here.
Hey Buddy.
All walkie and talkie.
How you doing?
Hi.
You say hi.
Can you say you like the frog on bugs bunny?
You like Kelo my baby.
Hell,
am I hunting the second I asked you to talk,
you won't talk in the podcast.
Sweet.
Can you say hi?
Hi.
Say Hi.
She'll do it when I buried it was right there.
Yeah,
just run over all my stuff in here.
It's just,
it's just stuff.
Hi.
Okay.
She's waving.
You know what's funny about her?
Hi.
You're desperate ones.
What she,
what she say like high means everything to her when she was just going to,
hi.
Hi.
She was pointing at pictures up on the,
up on the,
uh,
the wall that she wants to see.
Huh?
Hi Cutie.
I get a finished doing the read here.
All right,
bye.
All right.
Hey Sweetheart.
Did you know that he likes sleep?
If you want to,
if you want to personalize mattress that you're going to outgrow in two days,
go to,
he would sleep.com size per take.
Those simple two to three minutes sleep plays that quiz.
I already said that for couples,
they even personalize each side of the mattress.
Everyone from Gq to cosmopolitan t need to New York Times and talking about
headaches,
sleep.
And once you try it out,
he gonna know why you're custom mattress arrives direct to your door in a week
and shipping is completely free.
Try it for a hundred nights.
If you don't love it,
they'll pick it up,
Ross and refund you in full.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/per right now and you'll get $50 towards your custom metrics.
That's hell.
sleep.com/birth for $50 off your order.
He likes sleep.com/burb all right,
son.
Backset says we'll see basket,
it says be a k s e.
T.
All right,
my health seeking friends.
Ah Right.
I LC in France take to the day of not following through with resolutions are oh
because the day of sun basket it is sun basket are beginning which means you're
going to keep your rev resolution this year because sun basket makes it easier
than ever and today you can get $30 off your first order when you go to sun
basket.com/bar well what the fuck is it?
You got to tell us what it is before they're going to order it.
Okay.
When you have healthy meals regularly delivered to your door was sun basket.
It's easy to stay on track.
I'm talking ingredients like organic produce,
responsibly raised meats now all walk to near the fence.
Mr Cow,
sustainably sourced fish,
organic pasture raised eggs and organic non GMO Tofu.
Oh and house made sauces.
You can't find anywhere else what his housemate,
they,
they literally have a house where they make the sauce and it's personalized.
Sun Basket lets you mix and match from Paleo leaning clean,
gluten free,
Vegan,
vegetarian,
Mediterranean and more.
Not to mention tons of variety with 18 recipes to choose from each week.
Best of all,
each delicious easy recipe is ready and about 30 fucking minutes with sun
baskets.
Sun Basket,
you have total flexibility.
You can cancel anytime.
Skip anytime and choose any meal plan you want.
Go to sun basket.com/burr to to learn more and get $35 off your first order.
That's sun basket.com/ [inaudible] for $35 off sun basket.com/burr.
Mmm Oh my God,
you guys,
you know what I did on,
on uh,
I went to church with my whole family.
Okay.
Uh,
my mother in law was like,
listen,
you guys should go to church.
They're going to have a Dixie land band.
And,
uh,
you know,
it means a lot to her.
So like,
all right,
we'll go right.
So I go there and,
uh,
they have this FALive band comes in,
they playing when the saints go marching in the fucking killing it.
It's a bunch of old guys.
Okay.
You don't Trump a Trump owned tuba clarinet.
A Guy Paulino marching down with the snare drum playing that New Orleans jazz
shit.
It was fucking awesome.
And I remember just thinking like if they,
if they did this every week,
I would,
I would go all the time.
Why is this a once a day,
once a year,
like Mardi gras mass.
Um,
but I gotta admit I actually enjoyed going there with my family even though,
you know,
I don't buy into all of the guilt and you know,
he did know in all of that shit.
Um,
you know what's funny is my daughter does this thing,
well,
you know,
they'd like deal,
she's like trying out her voice and she kind of learned that she can go like way
down low lag.
Right?
So she kinda that we call it the monster,
like do the monster,
and she just goes like blah,
blah,
blah.
Right?
So we're at church and the preacher's talking and all that shit,
you know,
so I'm bored,
right?
So I start whispering in her ear,
I'm going to go to the monster,
do the monster.
So he's up there telling Jesus stories,
right?
And my daughter starts going like,
wow.
Ah,
like she was possessed.
It,
he is getting all mad at me and I keep telling her to do what it was fucking,
it was killing me and I get in.
Jesus saw the leper and he wasn't afraid to touch him and he showed that love is
the answer.
And my daughter's going,
wow.
Everything with her head spinning around.
Um,
oh,
we had such a good fucking time.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I actually enjoyed going,
it was sort of a tea,
you know,
I used to go every week with my family and everything and I actually think it's
a good thing if you don't a hundred percent buy in,
at least with my religion,
that this,
this is the only thing that you can worship.
This is the only way to do it.
And all of that shit.
Some actually thinking about going to church,
which then what would you do if I just slowly became this,
this psycho conservative,
not like a regular decent conservative person,
you know,
cause I don't have any beef with those people.
I feel like I'm liberal.
Although out here in Hollywood,
people think I voted for Trump.
That's how liberal it is out here.
Um,
but uh,
what would you guys do if I fucking went down that whole road and started going,
you liberal snowflakes,
you know,
Yay.
Taken my gun
back when the people said,
you know when they wrote this shit at you have the right to bear arms even
though they didn't have any concept of a machine gun and what the fuck that
could do?
Um,
I,
okay,
so here's the thing,
I would like to hear from people that are into guns.
What is your solution?
How do you prevent cause this,
they sell a zillion of those fucking things a year,
right?
I have no stats on this,
but I know,
I know they sell it because if I was in the guns that's what the fuck I would
want.
I would want a fucking machine gun cause that's like the Ferrari.
Every gun nut.
I'm every car nut once a fucking,
you know a supercar
so I totally get if you were in the guns like dude,
I,
you know what?
I can't get that now cause this fucking asshole does that.
So how about this?
All right,
you going to know way more about this.
So much.
Somebody that's in the guns.
All right and has one of those guns and all that type of shit.
What is your solution?
Because it just seems like whenever this happens,
liberal people go,
you know,
we got,
I,
we got a bad fucking assault.
Well we got back and read it every day.
They go that way.
And then people on the right say,
uh,
you know,
we,
we don't need to ban guns.
We,
this is alluded tick problem.
It's not a gun issue.
It's a loan,
a tick prom.
Um,
and I find it,
I find that fascinating because,
uh,
they keep using the ar 15,
you know,
and they're literally killing children.
It's schools
and people are still like defending.
That's,
that's fascinating to me.
So I would like to know what the argument is without you yelling and flipping
the fuck out.
I'm just asking just so I can understand it.
That's all I want to do.
I don't need to listen to fucking you conservative Jesus,
freak,
fucking liberal snowflake,
all of that fucking childish shit.
Cause we all know that.
I don't do name calling.
I'm just,
yeah,
interesting to me.
Like,
I love my Jaguar,
but if once every six weeks someone drove it through his school and ran people
over and they wanted to be like,
hey,
you know,
I don't know what it is about that car,
but these fucking people won't stop doing that with the car.
I would get another car,
I would just get a different one.
I'd be all right with that.
Personally,
it's just a car.
Cars don't kill people.
Lunatic should be fucking,
but you know all of that shit.
Guns don't kill people.
People kill people.
Well then why would you want to give them guns if that's what they're going to
do?
Can we,
can we raise the degree of difficulty?
Okay.
How about this?
How about if you're under age?
If you're up school age,
the only gun they'll give you as a revolutionary war era one where you got to
take out that rod and pack it down,
you know,
take out the tea bag,
when a little gunpowder.
How about you're only allowed to have one of those that work?
No,
because that fucking asshole in Las Vegas was a of a certain age.
I wonder how you could do it.
There's gotta be some sort of space,
age thing that you could do.
You know what I mean?
What if you get the,
I just like some big brother's shit.
They somehow like,
it's like,
uh,
if you get an assault weapon,
then this some millennial who has to sit there and every time you pick it up has
to be watching what you're aiming it at and they have a kill switch so they can
either turn it on just,
I don't know how to fucking do I,
why do I act like I have solutions,
whatever.
I would just,
you know what,
I would just at this point,
it's so depressing to see this shit and the frequency that it happens.
It would,
it would,
I at least at the very least,
if the could just be some calm,
rational,
somehow discussion of it with some solutions that just seemed like he could just
make this stop,
talk that,
make this stop talking,
make the stop happening.
Um,
so what do you miss?
I Dunno.
I don't fucking know.
So anyway,
I,
so I go to church,
right?
And my daughter started getting fussy and shit like that and she wanted to crawl
around the floor.
It's like,
I'm not going to add,
let you crawl around the floor.
All right?
So I just get up,
I walked to the back of the church or whatever and I sit down there and in the
end,
you know,
in my religion you go up and you get the,
uh,
the Eucharist.
All right.
And I had done it in a long time and I had not also been absolved of my sins.
I didn't go into the little walk in closet with the fucking creep,
tell him all the shit that I did,
just so fucking weird.
It's so dumb.
So I walk up there and I don't know,
I just was like dealing with my daughter and then I was dealing with the fact
that I felt like I was in a crowd.
So I kind of went into like,
after my show mode and I wasn't really thinking,
uh,
and the lady goes,
she goes to the body of Christ and I said,
hey,
thanks a lot.
She looked at me weird and then I took it.
It wasn't until I ate it,
I realize what I just said to her.
You supposed to say body Christ is supposed to say Amen I suppose.
Say Hey,
thanks a lot.
Like I was literally like after shows when I'm walking out,
you know,
and people,
Hey,
I do really judge.
thanks a lot.
You just,
hey man,
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Just go into this fucking mode so you can get from point a to point B.
I went into that mode for whatever reason,
cause my daughter was all fussy and I could tell she needed a diaper change and
my wife had the,
all this stuff and she was up at the front.
I was dealing with all of that Shit Shit.
And then I was like in a crowd,
the body of Christ,
Hey,
thanks a lot.
That's gotta be up there.
Top five things you're not supposed to say.
Right.
What are some other things that you probably shouldn't say?
The body of Christ Gross,
right?
Can't say that.
Hey,
can I get another one of those things?
I didn't have breakfast.
Uh,
Hey,
can I get another one?
This one seems a little stale
things you shit,
this is like a talk show plays and jellies and things.
You shouldn't say when accepting the EUCHARISTIC.
Um,
but I actually did enjoy,
I actually really enjoyed going,
I can't fucking believe it.
And um,
I talked to my,
my laugh and she's also a non church going where we'll for Hollywood phoneys
people.
Okay,
we're safeness.
We don't go to church.
Right.
Um,
she was actually,
you know what,
I enjoyed it too.
It's kind of a nice tradition or whatever,
you know,
that's part of being a parent,
making your kid get up earlier than the kid wants to and making them dress up to
go to some shit they don't want to go to.
So we make God,
you know,
there's something about doing that to your kid that um,
makes them not be a spoiled Brat.
We used to always go to church and then afterwards we would go to Dunkin donuts.
We get a dozen donuts and then we,
we wake up the morning,
we do our paper routes and my dad would us around me and a Chevy Chevette and we
would load it up with all these Sunday papers.
We'd have the hatchback open and we'd be,
me and my older brother be riding with their legs hanging out the back because
my dad was like in fourth gay,
what Brad Brad drag driving down the street.
He did Gospel music blaring
and uh,
we will be running around and he loved it.
He loved it.
My Dad wants people never gets cold either.
He'd always have the fucking window down.
And um,
why one of my elder brothers,
we put in the papers together in the back seat and then all the ones that were
ready to be delivered where we're in the way back in and we would just be
running and we would come home
and uh,
then put on church clothes.
We'd drive,
go to church,
then we'd go to Dunkin donuts.
And me coming to the every fucking Sunday from the time I was in third grade
right up until high school.
I mean,
I had a paper forever.
I always had a job,
you know,
from third grade on,
I had money,
I had all his kids I went to school with.
They're just like,
ah,
you know,
I broke.
The parents are bad.
They will give me money to get a fucking paper route.
Anytime I want to football cards,
I could buy them.
Okay.
You know,
I want it.
That's all I did.
I bought football cards and hockey cards,
baseball cards,
and I bought candy.
That was it.
That was my fucking overhead.
Okay.
And then when I went to school,
if I wanted lunch,
if I wanted doubles,
I always had money,
never on a number and just said these fucking kids like they'd be like in
seventh,
eighth grade,
still go to their parents for money.
Um,
I was independent.
All right.
Enough with me fucking blowing myself here on the podcast above.
What a hard worker,
Ryan.
All right,
that is the podcast.
All right?
God bless you for not having a gun.
God bless you for having a gun responsibly.
You know what?
God bless everyone.
All right?
Except for these assholes that go into schools and do what they do and for the
love of God,
can you stop fucking putting their faces all over the place and giving them
their 15 minutes of fame.
You know what I mean?
Like they appreciate it.
Okay.
Go out and do some fucking open mikes and do some hotel rooms for 20 years
before you get anything.
Okay?
Giving it to these fucking assholes overnight.
All right.
I'm in Santa Barbara Tonight.
I'm up there with Dean del Rey and Paul Versey.
Ed,
uh,
I'm going to fly him up and
I ain't want,
I'm flying.
I'm flying with the instructor by the way.
I did my first solo in about a year and a half.
Uh,
I flew like 20 something hours already this year.
And uh,
my auto rotations are fucking,
we would,
we did this thing,
my instructor,
we will coming in for landing and as I was turning base,
he just goes engine failure and just chop the throttle and he goes,
put it down on the numbers and I had to do like fucking ass turns.
I was coming in too fast and I fucking put it right down on the numbers and he
goes,
dude,
the fucking nailed it.
That was all you.
I one of the best compliments I ever got.
And um,
I ended up uh,
solo in a few days later and I just flew around the bay,
the basin out of Burbank,
in fact,
into Burbank.
And I did everything.
Great radio calls were great.
It was a really windy day.
I just flew slow and
it was funny,
I was listening to the atus was just basically the recording the information,
you know,
wind is still the seven and all that bullshit.
Right?
And then they,
in the end they always go,
you know,
Information Mike or Information Bravo.
Right.
I have everything fucking down and I'm nervous about Landon in Burbank because
you know,
it's a busy fucking airport.
Right.
And uh,
I swear to God it sounded like the guy,
this computer voice,
he said information Ricky.
I'm like,
what the fuck is Ricky?
This is just basically for pilot nerds and like what the fuck?
So I'm going go,
obviously he didn't say Ricky cause it's Romeo.
It's not Ricky fucking Ricardo.
What are we talking about here?
So now I got to think like,
what the fuck did they just say that sounded like Ricky buddy is alone.
Alpha Bravo,
Charlie Delta.
But I'm flying getting into their airspace.
So if I just said fuck it,
I said Burbank Tower Helicopter Blahblahblahblahblah at the Hollywood sign
requesting fullstop at Atlantic.
I listened to the 80s but I don't know what information to this,
but I know it's that Ricky,
when I landed,
my instructor goes,
Ricky,
he goes whiskey.
And I was like,
oh,
all right.
So there's always something.
And uh,
so I went in and they,
they told me to hold,
they call it old Maaco.
It's the Macy's out by the one 70.
And they said your number three.
So I see a southwest coming in and then there's some little Cessna and I can't
find the guy.
But at this point I know basically where to look.
And I know where the runway is.
It's like,
well,
I'll just fucking look over there and I'll keep doing my little left orbits
here.
And then I saw the guy and then I was like,
alright.
And he fucking went in landed.
And when we know where you landed,
Burbank,
there's always a tailwind now when you land,
but when you,
you go right as you go to set the fucking helicopter down,
this is fucking ridiculous tailwind.
And I always sit there stirring the pot and if somebody finally told me,
no,
it's shipped pedals,
you're pells keep it straight.
So I got myself a little straight straight and just sorta stabbed it,
set it down,
rolled down.
And now he said this the same thought I always have.
All right,
I didn't kill myself.
Um,
and I had a great time when I was up there,
right?
And then of course I get in,
you know,
this,
this allegedly really dangerous thing that I'm doing flying,
you know,
I get in my car and I get on the highway and what do I see?
Some massive fucking accident on the highway,
which is what happens every fucking time.
And the more I fly the lesson,
I'm afraid in a good way.
I'm still super conscious of being up there and it is that fear goes down every
time I get on.
I'm like,
like an old man now.
When I get on the highway,
I'm fucking terrified at how fast people go,
how they pass on the right other on their fucking phones.
You always know when somebody is on their phone,
especially if you're in like traffic,
you know what I mean?
Is because like the person in front of you start in front of them,
starts driving and they just don't move for like eight seconds.
Then you feed psyches.
This person's literally on their phone right now,
like reading tweets.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
that is the podcast.
Uh,
here's some fucking music for you.
And then we got a half hour of a Thursday afternoon podcast from back in the day
or a couple of Thursdays ago.
All right.
That's it.
Have a great weekend.
You see?
I'll talk to you on Monday.
Does
she was,
yeah,
no
touch day advice.
Billy by Derris billion.
I know this is last minute.
I had a question about Valentine's Day.
I am a single guy in my mid twenties rejoice,
dude,
I'm going to tell you right now,
if you're a single guy in your mid twenties and you live in America and you're
living on your own,
please
drop to your knees and thank whatever God you pray to every day because you're
never going to be free or in your life.
I know you've probably got student loans and blah,
blah,
blah.
This stress and all that bullshit.
Fuck that,
okay?
Getting never going to be freer in your life.
Go get three years supplies of condoms,
okay,
and bang away my friend.
Maybe you don't need to do it for three years.
Maybe you're one of those guys for only three weeks,
but you need to get it out of your system.
All right?
He says,
I never really had a girlfriend for whatever reason.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
All right,
we're going the whole other other way.
Truth be told,
my friends could name numerous reasons why I don't have a girlfriend,
but that's an entirely different issue.
What?
Jesus Christ as a fucking can of worms.
They can,
you don't seem defensive or argumentative.
So I dunno if it's an anger issue,
outlook.
I'm so,
I'm so sick of trying to be fucking Hannibal Lecter here to try to guess what
your shoes look like with w with the way you write,
you know.
All right.
I'm just going to read the rest of the shit.
Uh,
as of right now,
I am currently sleeping with three girls off.
Oh,
see you fucking,
you get knocking it out.
I thought you'd like never had a girlfriend like in,
you'd never bagged anybody.
All right.
My fault.
To go fuck yourself.
You're a guy in your mid twenties and you fucking three girls right now and
this,
you need advice.
I keep doing what you're doing
anyways,
depending on what day of the week it is and how much I've drank.
Okay.
That depends on how many girls he's banging a,
I've never lied to anything,
any of any of them about where our relationship is going.
And although they never met each other,
each of them has an idea that I'm seeing other girls.
It's kind of a don't ask,
don't tell policy.
Uh,
yeah,
dude and I,
you got to come with that.
You know,
you can open with that.
what are you doing?
I'm dating,
I'm playing the field.
Find people you date right now.
A couple of people kind of see him just having a good time.
Well,
I anti stuff like that.
Well there's the door sweetheart,
then they'll respect like that.
The honesty of that.
Some won't.
Some will actually have self esteem and walked out,
but a lot of them they'll hang around eventually.
They get tired,
they're neck gets weak and they'll fall right in your fucking Dick.
Um,
birthdays and Christmas are always a piece of cake because all that requires a
quick text or a phone call or at the very most drinks at the bar.
But Valentine's Day is tricky.
Our dates consist of bar hopping and drunk sex.
So flowers and a nice dinner would completely send the wrong message.
Dude,
you selfish cunt.
Are you asking me how to keep banging these three chicks while getting through
Valentine's Day?
Why don't you just look at the Valentine's Day like that's your pussy getting
all star break.
Just take three days off the day before the day after and the day of just say a,
what are you doing for Valentine's Day?
Um,
ah,
I'm going to be a Jesus.
Where are you going to be?
I don't even know.
I don't have a good one for that one.
All right.
You know what?
I just put myself in your shoes and I understand your problem now.
He said,
I got to do a little bit of trouble.
Last year one of the girls texted me and said,
you know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day.
Okay.
He said,
I knew my response couldn't be.
Yeah,
but if I get you flowers then they have to get flowers for all of the other
girls.
So I just post out and responded.
Yeah,
well,
oh dude,
you shouldn't respond to it at all.
Okay.
You know,
every girl likes to get flowers on Valentine's Day.
Isn't that funny?
Okay.
And that has nothing to do with most likely her having any sort of feelings
towards you.
It's just a bitch next to her in the other cubicle.
Probably got some,
you know,
while the girl on their fucking,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
Some guy broke my balls this week is fucking hilarious.
He was trashing me,
say,
come off as a pompous ass because I always talk about,
okay,
anybody who doesn't do comedy works in a cubicle,
you know,
and for some reason he decided to take that seriously and tell me that he
actually works at the UN and travels all around the world.
Okay.
If that's actually true,
sir.
How,
why don't you just get on with doing that?
You work at the UN and you travel all over the world.
Why would you give a fuck what some absolute jackass is?
Say It on a fucking podcast.
How insecure are you?
Your insecurities?
Probably a great thing because that's probably the thing that drove you to be at
the UN where you travel all around the world.
You know what,
sir?
Good for you.
That's awesome.
I hope working at the UN and traveling all around the world fills you up some
point where it fills you up high enough.
What?
You don't have to respond to a silly joke on some dumb ass podcast.
Um,
I travel all around the world.
you know what?
That's actually a great fucking job.
Do you feel like you get anything done?
You know,
do you sit there and wearing that headpiece next to that guy who's wearing the
water buffalo hat?
I'd bet they'd be the above doing that shit.
And you're sitting there trying to talk to him about how you can sell your Ritz
crackers to their country.
Is that what you're doing when you're traveling?
All around the where I travel all around the world.
Okay.
I can just see you on the plane with the fucking dress socks on.
You have a dash cunt.
Oh,
just sitting there.
Or what movies am I going to watch on this flight as I travel all around the
world?
Um,
anyways.
You know something sir,
you had you,
you had the James Bond job and then you fucking,
you played yourself.
I don't know why you did that.
Why would you fucking,
that's like me responding to people on Twitter.
Why would I do it?
I should pretend like I have better things to do.
Um,
anyways,
I want to keep seeing all these girls back to this guy,
but this,
but at the same time,
I don't want any broken hearts on Valentine's Day.
How to do you know what?
I did it.
I don't know.
Just what is your problem here?
Okay,
dude.
Yeah,
you like a Gemini.
It's like you're this fucking lady killer.
Then also you kind of like,
you know,
you don't want to hurt anybody.
Should I get her some jam jams?
Yeah,
I can't even,
I wouldn't talk to the fucking UN guy.
What the hell was going on here again?
Valentine's Day got a little trouble as well.
Listen,
you're anticipating trouble.
Didn't you learn anything from last year?
You know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day.
Um,
what,
what would I write back?
I know what my response would be.
The second I read that if it was just some girl I was banging and then they
wrote that I would get this awful feeling in my stomach
and I would,
I would read it.
And as I got that awful feeling,
I'd go
and make that noise.
You know that thing like when you're just banging a girl and then all of a
sudden she just fucking makes that comment.
You know,
you think she's on the same page as you.
When did,
she just makes that comment?
You know,
I was thinking about you today.
You just feel that feeling in your stomach.
Oh yeah.
Well don't
fucking worst.
Ah,
you gotta be one and done,
but one had done is scary.
You just gotta be honest.
I don't know if some girls,
what would I say?
You know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day.
Um,
what would I text back?
Yeah.
You know,
that's what I heard.
You know what I,
you know what?
I shouldn't give you shit.
I don't have a good response to that.
Well,
maybe some day you'll meet a guy who wants to give you some,
you want to get drunk and fuck,
yeah,
I got nothing and you can't ignore it.
You know what I would've done?
I would've ignored the texts and I would have called her.
But a good three hours later,
three,
four hours,
three hours later,
that's a good one.
You call her,
you ignore that text.
Then he called us,
she goes,
hell,
ah.
And he's like,
Hey,
what's going on?
What are you doing tonight?
I got no plans Valentine's Day.
What are you doing?
And he just started with that.
And then she,
well,
when he went to Dell and she'll be seen if you're going to take it and some
romantic,
you know,
direction and you don't,
you just keep it in the fuck buddy.
So I figure we'd go down to La,
meet hammers,
whatever the fuck he call,
we'd go down to,
uh,
take it the face.
I have a couple pitchers of beer and see what happens.
Dude.
You know what?
You're,
you're,
it seems to me you're not just fucking these girls.
You're actually having like these many relationships with them.
You know the,
the key to having a fuck buddy is,
is the time between fucking him.
And I don't give a shit how much a woman says that she can handle it.
Most of them can't.
If you fucking coming over there and you,
and it just,
eventually they're going to get feelings,
they're more,
I don't know if they're more,
or if it's a defect.
It's just,
I just respect the fact that that's how they're wired.
So you,
if you have a fuck buddy,
okay,
let's,
let's just do the math.
Okay,
now,
February is a very short month here.
So let's just say right out of the gate,
you fucker on February 2nd
all right?
You shouldn't come around again till at least the 17th and progress.
You Fuck and you leave FNL you fuck them and then you leave.
You don't bang her on the second.
You Bang it on the second and then you bang her on the seventh year in a fucking
relationship in their world.
You know,
unless you literally this second you have an orgasm as you're coming,
you're scooping up your clothes and you walk out like half naked,
then you just bizarre.
Which is another good way to keep them at bay.
And why don't I just read the rest as to see what it,
what is question this here he says,
I want to keep seeing all these girls,
but at the same time,
I don't want to break.
I don't want any broken hearts on Valentine's Day.
Yeah,
you want to keep fucking all of them now do what you have to have.
You have to have a road revolving door.
You have to have a stable of women.
If you're going to live this life or you have to give into fucking rubbing one
out,
all right?
But you can't be a relationship guy with three different women cause you are
going to end up hurting them.
So what you have to constantly be doing,
you gotta be like a college coach,
all right?
Every year you lose some top prospects,
but you're out there recruiting.
Okay.
See you.
So you maintain,
but it's never ending.
It's fucking exhausting.
But if that's the game you want to play,
that's what you have to do.
So that girl who says,
you know,
every girl likes flowers on Valentine's Day right there,
you put on waivers,
okay,
for for a fucking piece of ass to be named later,
you got got to get rid of her.
Okay.
And you got to look,
go back and analyze what the fuck you did wrong that she felt it was okay for
her to text you cause you fucked up.
That right there shows that you fucked up,
that she felt that she could send that to you if you think you just fuck
buddies.
All right?
So anyways,
he continues.
He says,
I know that like it or not,
this shit is important to women.
If I take one girl out,
I'm playing favorites and setting a bad precedent.
Plus if she does that check in Shit on Facebook,
I'm completely fucked.
Yeah Dude,
you're doing dirt bags.
Shit.
If you're a single guy and something could happen that fucks you on Facebook,
you're leaving these girls on anyways.
He says,
if I take none of them out or do nothing,
I have three irritable ladies on my hand.
Dude,
are you gonna marry any of them now?
Well then let them go.
Why don't you have the balls to do that?
You know,
when a team halfway through the season just realized,
did wait,
winning this shit.
Just pull a fucking Marlin's.
Just get rid of everybody
and then your fan base is your Dick and they're going be,
he's gonna be pissed for awhile.
Um,
but then you build it back up again.
Build it back up again.
You know,
I dunno,
look to it.
If you want to be in a fucking relationship,
you know there's other ways about going about it and doing this,
but you're trying to have your cake and eat it too.
Did you get you,
you got three women right now.
You're bang in three different women.
Where's your confidence?
You know what you're doing.
All right.
Dumped to keep one at bay and then get two more,
then dumped the other one and get the other one.
She sees him.
You don't even dump them.
You just phase them out,
phase them out.
But the new recruits that you get in,
you gotta be straight up honest with them,
you know,
unless you actually feel,
feel as you'd be feeling no feelings,
you know,
don't keep coming back fucking him unless,
you get that 15 day,
you fuck them on the second you fuck them on the 17th,
then you're into march and then banger on like the 11th.
All right.
And even then,
they can't catch feelings doing that.
But before you know it,
you know,
that's like 14,
15 days out of the year taken up.
Boy,
you,
well,
you got to bank somebody.
This is such,
this is,
this is really should be eye opening to women that I'm actually saying this is
really a,
this is really awful.
Not that I'm speaking this out loud.
Um,
he says,
in a perfect world,
I'll take all of them out at once and have the force and I've been chasing after
my entire life,
but we don't always get what we want.
Any advice from the lovely new would be much appreciated as well.
Love the podcast.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Uh,
yeah,
she probably wouldn't have been his,
uh,
understanding as I was,
even though I gave you a lot of shit.
Cool.